MORNING ON "FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
NOW TO MY OPENING STATEMENT.
YOU KNOW, AMERICANS ELECTED THE
OUTSIDER BUSINESSMAN PRESIDENT.
WHY?
TO BORROW A PHRASE FROM THE MAN
HIMSELF.
WHAT DO WE HAVE TO LOSE?
FACTORIES WERE CLOSING DOWN,
JOBS AND MANUFACTURING WERE
BEING SHIPPED OVERSEAS, AND IN
TRADE, CHINA WAS SUCKING US DRY.
THE OBAMA FOLKS CALLED IT A
HEALTHY ECONOMY BUT THERE WAS
BARELY A PULSE.
1% ANNUAL GDP GROWTH WAS THE NEW
NORMAL AND PRESIDENT OBAMA
WARNED DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION
WOULD RESULT IN ECONOMIC
DISASTER FOR ALL AMERICANS.
>> SOME OF THOSE JOBS OF THE
PAST ARE JUST NOT GOING TO COME
BACK.
AND WHEN SOMEBODY SAYS LIKE THE
PERSON YOU JUST MENTIONED WHO
I'M NOT GOING TO ADVERTISE FOR
THAT HE'S GOING TO BRING ALL
THESE JOBS BACK.
HOW EXACTLY ARE YOU GOING TO DO
THERE IS NO ANSWER TO IT.
HE JUST SAYS I AM GOING TO
NEGOTIATE A BETTER DEAL.
WHAT MAGIC WAND DO YOU HAVE?
AND USUALLY THE ANSWER IS HE
DOESN'T HAVE AN ANSWER.
>> I WANT TO YOU TELL YOUR
FRIENDS, DON'T LET A FRIEND VOTE
TRUMP.
SO HERE IS THE DEAL.
HE CAN'T ESCAPE THE MATH.
MATH CAN BE KIND OF
AND ECONOMISTS LEFT, RIGHT, IN
THE MIDDLE, ALL SAY THE SAME
THING.
THAT TRUMP'S POLICIES WOULD
THAT WE HAVE HAD SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION.
>> IN THE EVENT DONALD WINS I
HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THE
MARKETS TANK.
HIS TAX PLAN IN COMBINATION WITH
HIS REFUSAL TO REFORM
ENTITLEMENTS AND HONESTLY
ADDRESS SPENDING WOULD BALLOON
THE DEFICIT AND THE NATIONAL
DEBT.
SO EVEN THOUGH DONALD TRUMP IS
OFFERED VERY FEW SPECIFIC
ECONOMIC PLANS, WHAT LITTLE HE
HAS SAID IS ENOUGH TO KNOW HE
WOULD BE VERY BAD FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS AND AMERICAN FAMILIES.
JUDGE JEANINE: THEN WAS PAUL
KRUGMAN, A NOBEL PRIZE WING
ECONOMIST.
HE SAID THE STOCK MARKET WILL
PLUMMET AND NEVER RECOVER FROM
THE ELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP.
SO WE ARE VERY PROBABLY LOOKING
AT A GLOBAL RESPECIAL NO END IN
HATRED OF DONALD TRUMP, THEY
FORGET DECADES OF TRAINING IN
THEIR OWN FIELD.
AS AMERICA SURGES FORWARD WITH
MORE JOBS THAN PEOPLE TO FILL
THEM, WITH AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND
OFF FOOD STAMPS BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO WORK.
THE LEFT, THEY RANT AND PROTEST
AND CREATE CHAOS.
THP.
THEY THROW PEOPLE OUT OF
THEY EVEN GO TO CHURCH AND SAY
GOD SENT THEM TO DESTROY DONALD
ECONOMIC SUCCESS.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS MAKE
NOISE.
BUT IT'S NOTHING MORE THAN
BACKGROUND NOISE.
WHITE NOISE.
THE TRUTH?
NO ONE IS PAYING ATTENTION TO
THEM.
HIS NUMBERS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
AND HIS POPULARITY JUST KEEPS
GOING UP.
AFTER HE MET WITH PUTIN AND WAS
PUNISHABLE BY DEATH, HIS NUMBERS
THEIR YELLING AND SCREAMING IS
NOTHING BUT A DISTRACTION,
NOBODY CARES.
WE CARE ABOUT FOOD ON THE TABLE,
PAYING THE RENT, THE MORTGAGE,
PAYING FOR KIDS CLOTHING FOR
SCHOOL.
BUT NO, THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHORES AND PORN STARS OR A
LAWYER THEY ARE SQUEEZING SO
TIGHT HE'LL CONFESS TO SINKING
WHACK-A-MOLE RUSSIA COLLUSION
NONSENSE AND THE HATERS CONTINUE
TO HATE, THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE 45th OUTSIDER PRESIDENT
OFTEN WORK WITHOUT THE SUPPORT
OF HIS OWN PARTY HAS PRODUCED A
GDP THAT NO ONE THOUGHT
POSSIBLE, 4.1%.
AND WE ARE ON TRACK TO HIT THE
HIGHEST AVERAGE GROWTH RATE IN
OVER 13 YEARS.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT TO SAY TO
THAT, BARACK, HILLARY AND ALL
YOU GENIUSES?
WE ARE FLYING FOLKS.
THIS IS THE AMERICA DONALD TRUMP
HAD IN MIND WHEN HE ASKED US,